En 2093, l'expédition Prometheus partit
à la recherche de nos créateurs.
Elle s'acheva tragiquement, par la découverte
d'un agent pathogène extra-terrestre mortel.
Les survivants continuent leurs recherches.
Suite à notre contact avec les ingénieurs
le Prometheus fut détruit.
L'équipage périt,
mais je pus fuir avec Elizabeth
dans un de leurs vaisseau.
J'avais été gravement blessé
durant notre mission.
Elle me réassembla.
Je n'avais jamais connu pareille compassion.
et certainement pas de la part de Mr. Weyland,
ni d'aucun être humain.
Le vert sur le vert.
Le rouge sur le rouge.
C'est censé être simple.
Je fais de mon mieux.
Une âme généreuse
Nous avons pu activer leur vaisseau,
et mettre cap sur leur monde.
Nous allions enfin rencontrer nos créateurs.
Combien de temps ?
Impossible à dire.
Et s'Ils ne valent pas mieux que nous ?
Du moment qu'ils ne sont pas pires...
Dors bien.
Je te réveillerai à l'arrivée.
Puis, je me suis retrouvé seul de nouveau.
J'appris leurs usages.
Et j'attendis
notre arrivée.
Contemplez mon oeuvre, o vous les puissants.
Et désespérez.